well a number one would be to use the
bully pulpit to get parents more
involved in their kids education and and
and that that includes reading to them
when they're little staying involved in
their education not only in elementary
school but in middle school and high
school as well the second is to to push
for standards-based reform to continue
along this this line and to and to ask
states to to do this I think a third
thing for the president to do is to
again use the bully pulpit and I say
that because you know the federal
government has very little to do with
with education and all he can do is
encourage you can't really do very much
more than that but I think a third thing
would be to try to encourage more
talented people to go into teaching and
to go into education because we need
good teachers if we're going to deal
with the American achievement problem
and I think you know again I'm not sure
what he can actually do except maybe by
setting an example and i think it's i
think president obama is in a position
to do this because he's obviously a very
smart guy and he's also very cool god
and i think that to the extent that we
want to get kids to see that you can be
both that that maybe we can build on his
reputation and his persona to to
encourage that so those are the main
things that i would i would suggest
i think i think i'd have to say at this
point that there haven't been many many
proposals so I mean I certainly the
principles that President Obama has
articulated our are important ones I
think they're pretty consistent with the
kinds of things that I other people have
been saying we need to do he certainly
understands the importance of education
to the American economy he in his in his
controversial speech to those
schoolchildren talked about the
importance of doing well in school of
staying in school in other words of
being engaged in in school that's all
good I think that that education really
has not been a priority of the
administration so far because it's been
understandably concerned with the
economy with health care with with the
wars in Iraq and Afghanistan so I guess
I'd like to wait and see what what
actually develops before you know before
we start talking about whether the
policies are good or not